ja wir befinden uns hier gerade im
Design Center in Linz bei der IKT
Sicherheitskonferenz 2023 wir haben hier
verschiedenste Aussteller verschiedenste
Stände auch des Bundesheeres und hier
konkret ist der der Stand der
thesianischen Militärakademie wo wir die
Gäste über den neuen Studiengang
militärischeer IKT Führung informieren
worum geht es bei diesem Studiengang das
Bundesheer hat eigentlich die
Entwicklungen in der in der modernen
Kriegsführung erkannt vor allem die äh
die Entwicklungen in der cyberdomaine
und hat aus diesem Grund einen neuen
Studiengang eingerichtet der sich genau
schwergewichtsmäßig mit diesem Thema
befasst der Studiengang militärische IKT
Führung findet an der militärkemie in
wier Neustadt statt und ist ausgelegt
auf Führungskräfte die eben genau in
diesem in diesem Bereich Aufgaben
übernehmen und eben die Tätigkeiten zum
zum Schutz der Bevölkerung wahrnehmen
ein meiner helzeit mir die Technik schon
sehr passessiert und nach meiner
sechsjährigen Erfahrung als
Unteroffizier habe mir dann doch bum
zack h in die nächste Herausforderung
und besucht den Studiengang miliktf und
hier bin ich im dritten Semester und mit
guten Erfolg 25 ausmustern die drei
Hauptsäulen auf denen dieser Studiengang
aufbaut im Wesentlichen sind die
sogenannte elektronische Kampfführung
das bedeutet sowas wie störverfahren
pilverfahren weiters befassen wir uns
ganz stark mit dem Thema Cyber als
Ganzes das heißt wir bilden it
Grundlagen aus wir bilden sehr stark
sehr viel IT security aus nach meiner
zöljährigen Erfahrung beim bundesjahr
und abschlussfunktion als zugskommandant
habe ich neue Herausforderungen gesucht
und musste erkennen dass die Technik die
Zukunft ist und deswegen studiere ich an
der Militärakademie militärische
informations und
kommunikationstechnologische
Führung und der dritte Bereich mit dem
wir un befassen ist die IKT die
informations und
Kommunikationstechnologie also quasi die
klassische fernmelderei so wie man sie
kennt inklusive Kabelbau inklusive
Richtfunk Verbindungen wo es darum geht
eben die Verbindungen des Bundesheeres
für Einsätze sicherzustellen oder auch
eben für Blackout Szenarien diverse
Verbindungen und Kommunikationsmittel
bereitzustellen unsere studierend
beginnen mit eben einer Grundausbildung
mit einer akademischen Ausbildung im
itbereich wir haben auch eine
Ausbildungsabschnitte an der
führungsunterstützungsschule und
letztenendes ist es das Ziel
Führungskräfte hier zu generieren nicht
wie man es vielleicht meinen könnte
Nerds sondern wirklich Führungskräfte
und Offiziere die sich in diesem
Tätigkeitsfeld betätigen und
Führungsaufgaben übernehmen mir hat das
bundesher mögllich die
Studienberechtigungsprüfung zu machen
und das innerhalb der Dienstzeit
dahingehend jetzt die Möglichkeit
einfach den Studiengang zu besuchen und
meine Qualifikationen einfach zu
erweitern und meinen Tellerand der für
mich dann nach einer Zeit begrenzt war
diesen zu
erweitern
[Musik]
ه